so what's the best part about internet
video well let me tell you it's the fact
that nobody has any idea that I'm
wearing blue flannel pants right now
everybody's got a question
welcome to ask IJ where I answer your
questions
canopy from Twitter asks if you could
adopt a panda and have it live in your
home would you
hey Justine I love your product reviews
if I were to send you a product would
you review with on their tear really
five four six seven eight four three two
four six seven eight nine two two got a
lot of numbers in your name well Billy I
get a lot of requests for product
reviews so that's why we made this
website I just steamed up overlay TV
only place to get me to review any you
just have to put it together overlay
said that they're going to give one we
away to the best iJustine product review
for more details check my blog and check
it out
your response question over here yeah I
just seen are you married or something
yeah I am Ethan pies me candy I guess
not but I thought you should be on the
lease just miss YouTube 2009 thanks for
subscribing and don't forget to check
out my other youtube channel youtube.com
slash other I just seen through behind
the scenes clips and the IJ after-show
also follow my Twitter twitter.com slash